hi i am dove cameron and it has been two
years and six days since i did the wired
auto complete interview but now
i'm back for part two
what if i just do the same answers for
everything like a psycho
who does cameron this is very exciting
this is my favorite i feel like it's
like ritualistic this is my favorite
holiday okay who is dove cameron related
to
i think i got this one last time
everybody thinks i'm related to james
cameron which i'm not but like oh my god
it would be amazing if i was i would
love to go
to the depths of the ocean and go on
like wacky adventures i might be getting
a lot of my information from that one
south park episode but listen james
cameron
if we are related distantly even please
take me on one of your wacky adventures
who does dove cameron love
that's so sweet there's something really
pure about that everyone
world peace who did dove cameron
guess it's yes
lazy baby i kissed a boy
named alexander 23.
no there's no follow-up to that
lazy baby is about a relationship that
was once beautiful and sort of the
realization that even if you love
someone you need to choose your own
well-being over suffering for the sake
of a relationship that is no longer
working who was dove cameron in hocus
pocus
i have to love that because i'm not in
hocus pocus is the first reason i have
to love that but the second reason is
because kenny ortega directed it and i
did um a halloween special at the
hollywood forever cemetery in 2018 where
i sang winifred's lead role and it was
one of the most fun things i've ever
done in my life oh my god what i
wouldn't give to be a sanderson sister
also i literally worship at the altar
that is sarah jessica parker i mean
every single person it's an iconic film
i mean come on who does dub cameron
voice in marvel rising
i voice gwen stacy
aka ghost spider and i thought that that
was one of the coolest things ever and i
love the fact that gwen stacy in our
version gets her own life where she gets
to be sort of a spider-man esque like in
the spider verse she gets to have her
own like ghost spider adventures and she
has her own powers it's very sexy of her
thanks
what are dove cameras
hobbies that's sweet because i don't
know why anybody would care about that
y'all i work so much i'm like my hobbies
are like eating so and i'm not just like
being like eating so much ice cream but
like truly if i have time off i am like
attempting to be a non-entity the other
night i got home from this performance i
did with res
and i got home from like a really long
drive and i ordered enough sushi for
like a family of seven and i ate it all
in one sitting and i think i had to get
up early the next morning and i chose
that life
what is dove cameron's favorite fruit
watermelon
next
what kind of car does dove cameron drive
i think people know what it is because i
feel like i talk about it enough i drive
a convertible i drive a black
convertible and for safety reasons i
think that's all i can say but it's very
fast i feel very connected with my car
it's got a name it's name is lucy what
mascara does dove cameron use the one
i'm using right now
i think it's like a gucci in like a sort
of a nude ballet colored tube with like
a gold top this is what i'm gonna tell
you about eyelash health it's about
preservation so i use mascara that is
like very very easy to get off i also um
hardly wear any if i don't look like
this i look absolutely like nothing
you've ever seen before i look like a
shower drain creature and that's why my
skin is so so clear
it's because i never really look like
this so it's not about the mascara you
know it's actually about the the lack of
mascara what is dove cameron's job
that's gonna be the funniest thing
that's happened to me today uh you tell
me you guys i mean i'm an actor
and a singer that's definitely my job
but i feel like mostly what people see
me do is like i do a lot of press i do a
lot of photo shoots i do a lot of like
modeling weirdly which is not my job it
shouldn't be so hard to answer this
question
i'm an actor and a singer but i love
that you don't know and that apparently
i don't either what are dove cameron
fans called i think it was like a long
time ago like the dudleys but i don't
really think that that's like a thing
really anymore do people have fan names
anymore what is dove cameron's hogwarts
house get into my government information
here i go back and forth about thinking
if i'm slytherin or gryffindor i kind of
gotta go with slytherin i know people
are gonna hate me for that but i have
two snakes tattooed on my body i had a
huge crush on draco when i was a kid
first of all
traumatized always picks the bad boy
even when i was little
red flags um honey rose colored glasses
everything is red that made sense in my
mind tell me if it made sense on the
outside
and then i think as i got older and by
that i mean like when i was 13 this is
weird but like severus snape he had that
deep voice 394.
um what is doug cameron's favorite
disney princess oh
i have a hack for this because disney
just acquired fox right so anastasia and
last time you said ariel i don't know as
i've gotten older i'm like not all about
someone who's willing to lose their
voice and their personality for a man
i'm just not also anastasia she's she's
badass she was a scrappy street kid and
she knew what she wanted and she was
willing to leave dmitry when she
realized listen she we love her
what is dove cameron doing now talking
to you
text me i'm doing this interview i'm
also promoting
my new tv show schmigadoon on apple tv
how is dove
how is dove cameron dating uh just like
anybody else i guess i am dating someone
right now this was a lot easier when i
had like a very public boyfriend because
everyone just knew everything
i love arcades and
bowling mini call i like activities so i
would say i'm dating
well how did doug cameron get on disney
i have no idea i mean like i auditioned
i um i booked something called bits and
pieces that that later turned into liv
and maddie i only played one character
originally in the pilot and then they
were like she's got so much personality
let's make her too it's essentially i
think what happened so yeah i don't know
the old-fashioned way how did dove
cameron change her name legally
at the courthouse
i raised my hand and everything most
people who are close to me call me chloe
and most people at work call me dove
because it just got too confusing i
tried to integrate chloe back into my
work life and then one of my directors
who had worked with for like years was
like who the is chloe i was like
okay this is
this is not gonna work how many cats
does dove cameron have only two
i don't like the intention behind that
question like i have nine their names
are peanut butter and cheesecake they're
both rescues they're both so sweet and
very very social they both got a lot of
personality and they fight all the time
okay is jeff cameron vegetarian no
i'm not i try to be vegan for a long
time
i'm vegan off and on but i have not yet
figured out a way to do it where i don't
feel like incredibly sick all the time
even with the right supplements and
loads of vegetables and things like that
is def camera really blonde yes i am not
this blonde though
is dove cameron really singing all the
time
i am really singing all the time you
wouldn't like it is dub camera soprano
or an alto i am
what is technically called a coloratura
soprano but i talk and i scream so much
that you hear just all the rasp and like
i am gargling gravel all the time is
dove cameron going to be rapunzel you
tell me you make the call i will be
there is dev cameron going to be in
spider-man 3. no
is deaf cameron related to christmas no
but you know something so funny is one
of my like
main makeup artists the other day was
watching an interview with me and
kristen and she was like oh is that not
your mom and i was like what no she's
not my mom in the show and she was like
no no this whole time i thought that was
your real birth mom so that was my cue
to call kristen and be like we gotta we
gotta not work together so much because
this my my mom's gonna get her feelings
hurt but actually at this point i am
kind of related to kristin jenna with
feels like after a while like our just
our dna is like bonding we're
we're cauterizing
does stuff cameron play basketball no
and i can't believe disney would ever
put me on a show where i was the captain
of the basketball team do you guys know
how short i am unrealistic but you know
what i'm really really good at because
of liv and maddie is pop a shot i will
kick your ass at papa shot and that's a
guarantee money back
does dove cameron have green eyes yes
i literally felt that i was like you
want the special on these eyes
does job cameron
voice the minions no way
no way that my impression was that good
that you literally think i actually
voiced the minions seiko's right there
cinco created bullsh megadis and
despicable me and he's literally right
there laughing
thank you
i got the part
thank you that is the stupidest thing
i've ever done here now does dovecamera
know ariana grande yes she is one of my
favorite people alive she's one of the
most amazing people on planet earth we
love ariana in this house does dove
cameron write her own songs i work with
co-writers on some songs
but i i read all my songs
thank you so much wired this was very
fun and i can't wait to see you for the
next one thanks guys